as we saw in the previous code example
properties can have different types
these are called property types for the
recipe kind some of the property names
and types were name which was a string
vegetarian a boolean indicator and the
number of servings an integer but these
are just a few property types in fact
datastore supports a lot more property
types and we mean a lot the official
documentation on developers.google.com
lists around 20 of them in this class
we're only going to use a small subset
of these and the ones you can see listed
here are some of the most common
properties integers floating point
numbers strings dates and binary data